ramage the drive right on Saved By Smith rebound
ramage to the Blue Line nobody home and that could
be a goal for the Islanders Rob ramage just
shot it into his own net 128 left and hexall
able to clear it out boy he could score a goal
sometimes in a situation like this hexall is
so strong in clearing traps it here he goes
bidding for one here's the clear here it is
he scored hexall scored a goal on the empty net
and you can see that he is so strong at it that
is a legitimate one but this is the first time
in my 40 years being around this game that I've
actually seen a goal tender do that I have never
seen that happen here comes Scott Stevens to
Center drives it in Peters makes his way to the
bench capitals throw on a six the attacker and
the puck bouns all the way down and into the goal
the goenda goal Rod hexall has done it now in the
playoffs he did it once before against the Boston
Bruins during a regular season game and here does
it in the Stanley Cup Playoffs shooting it from
his own goal behind the goal line all the way
down the ice and into the net for the Whalers
Wesley out to Center DS it in OS good handles
looks to clear it himself he does going for the
empty goal Chris o good scores Chris o good does
the inable and ices the cake here in Hartford
you don't see that too often to say the least
that's a happy Bunch on the Red Wing side Manson
blasts it back around rodor controlling the net
is empty he throws it down and and he scored
a goal Maran bror all right Maran oh is he a
happy man oh can you believe it he couldn't have
written a better scenario well he can look up at
the big board and watch this and that's just what
he's doing Pand offo chipped it along it'll be a
penalty on the senator centering pass oh and a
great backhander was stopped by Damen rhods as
letting it go was odine andri Chuck hands on to
Neer trickled one that was away from rson oine
flung it it went all the way down will it go in
yes Damen rhods gets credit for the goal as the
last guy to touch the puck so he didn't put it
in off his own stick as bror has and hexall has
and Chris Osgood has but he gets credit for the
goal grenberg around behind put one out in front
that's paddled Away by bodor and there'll be a
penalty coming up penalty against the Devils this
one thrown back out and stepping fresh From the
Bench is G on the delayed penalty call and it's
deflected back into the goal it'll count well
martan broor has been getting given credit for
the goal he touched it there was he the last yes
he was it's a delayed call so bodor gets a regular
season goal credited to him it ties him with Ron
hex consider the 10 of their final 13 are on the
road they really needed to make up some points
here teodor launched that all the way down is
that going to go in Jose teodor has scored a
goal the montre all Canadians golender Jose
teodor has hit the empty net with 8.1 seconds
remaining in the third period three to nothing
Montreal and from the remainder of the 7900 here
at the Coliseum a standing ovation how about that
nasland with a minute to go he'll lift this ahead
novakov knocks it down and he'll try and score you
getting novakov he's gone he did Yakov has scored
the first goal in his NHL career and that puts
the cherry on top of this game then he fires it
right down the ice and picks the corner no less
in front here's another chance CLE can't get a
shot no under a minute to go great Leaf pressure
kick loose of right oh look out he's going to
put it down into his own net Buffalo goal and
who gets credit they're congratulating mik noran
and I wonder I he made a save with the butt end
of his stick Here Comes Sanders and a blast
and that goes wide delayed penalty against the
Predators CH two two it goes back now to oh the
puck goes all the way down the ice it's scored
the pass and that kind of tifies the evening
for the coyotes they score on their own empty
net you know it might be it might be Mason's
goal you know that Mason me deceive it's played
across elos R shot save made by W kobal Chum to
periz back to Ilia kjop Dej goes to the bench
and the pass for Adam Henrik is Off the Mark and
unbelievably into the devil's goal and we can't
give you the goal score Steve it was whichever
Kane touched it last unbelievable it had been
thrashed around behind the net I don't think that
top Kane touches it with his stick short-handed
for the Hurricanes it's Patrick DWI who takes the
puck gets around Ilia Kovalchuk still going and
it's swept aside by broor and a penalty coming
up against new New Jersey back could this go in
yes delayed penalty here right there Marty
touches it but then guess they ruled he didn't
have control no other devil covered it and it's
in the net and this goal should be credited to
martan bror it will be from the Detroit R Wings
is Samuelson gets it back in down Willie it's in
yes are you kidding me no time on the
clock will it count the red lights on
they're going to check this one
the red light was on it's a good
goal
wow another look look at that up and over and
down Crawford will go to the bench again re will
try Reen going deep for the
empty net it is [Applause]
bouncing what a oh my god he has scored a
goal
[Applause] unbelievable oh he's been trying that
A couple of times over for the last few years
oh my God and what a perfect opportunity and he
buries the Blackhawks look at this this is just
a thing of beauty floats it all the way over the
neutral zone lands on the other side of the blue
line look at oh my gosh that was incredible Conor
Garland off besser's stick om Mark is going to try
it and he scores latus over Mark the oddson fut
Trophy winner scores an empty net goal to seal
this win you're seeing [Applause] history the
Sully [Applause] line and they've been battling
they battle back in the game they're battling
for these loose pucks jari he's going for the
net bouncing towards the goal he scores you have
witnessed history Tristan jari becomes the first
goenda actually score a goal wow was
that with some authority too Tristan
jari had himself a whale of a game
and oh yeah he just scored a goal wow